most Americans approve of Donald Trump
getting kicked off the ballot in
Colorado there's a new poll found that
54% of Americans approve of kicking
Trump off the ballot in Colorado that
includes 24% of Republicans so there you
have it by the way there is that
anti-trump lane 24% of people 24% of
Republicans would happily go to any
non-trump candidate whether that's going
to be Dan santis whether that's going to
be Nikki Haley whether that's Chris
Christie whoever they just hate Trump
that much and then the non-trump
candidate might be able to pry away
another 5% another maybe even another
10% almost a quarter of Republicans
happy that Trump has kicked off that
ballot and most Americans that's bad
democracy will not work under those
circumstances it can't